vous êtes pour ou contre l'avortement on
s'en fout c'est une question très
personnelle est-ce que vous êtes pour ou
contre l'avortement je suis pour
l'avortement si une femme n'a pas envie
d'avoir un enfant elle est libre à elle
de faire ce qu'elle veut de sa vie et de
son corpend oui je suis pour la liberté
de pouvoir choisir de garder un enfant
ou pas parce qu'en plus un enfant on se
le cotine toute la vie derrière donc si
on a pas envie au départ ça ça part mal
moi je suis contre l'avortement et pour
la contraception contre chacun doit être
libre de faire ce qu'il veut euh si
quelqu'un ne veut pas il le fait pas je
suis pas pour l'avortement je suis pour
le que les personnes aient le choix de
le faire ou non je suis pour
l'avortement je suis pour l'avortement
vous aussi pour l'avortement nous sommes
pour l'avortement la et oui
naturellement des préféren après
l'avortement l'avortement en soi est un
acte médical donc c'est pas pour au
contre un acte médical je suis pour la
le fait de pouvoir choisir si pratiquer
un acte médical je suis contre c'est une
vraie décadence je vois pas pourquoi on
forcerait une femme à avoir un enfant si
elle en a pas envie il y a tellement de
situations qui font que on peut avoir
une maternité pas pas désiré que je
trouve que c'est hyper important d'avoir
le choix du moment personnellement je
préfère l'avort dès lors que l' pour moi
l'enfant est viable euh je serai contre
dès lors que il est encore en état de
fétus pourquoi pas faut faut voir aussi
quelles sont les intentions on pourrait
éviter des avortements parce que il y a
des conséquences ça va meer d'abord sur
le plan moral et puis je sais pas mes
points de vue
stérilité je crois que il y a beaucoup
de jeunes qui se font avortter sont très
très jeunes et qui plus tard veulent
avoir des enfants et ont beaucoup de
difficultés après en avoir pour parce
que je pense qu'un accident peut arriver
et que du coup il vaut mieux interrompre
la grossesse que de forcer une personne
qui ne sent pas se sent pas prête à être
mère ou des gens qui se sentent pas
prêts à être parents à à avoir des
enfants
I